so I guess it's only fair that people
are mean to me on Twitter since I'm so
strict on Twitter see I have a rule if
you have digital courage or keyboard
courage which means you're willing to
say crap to me on Twitter that you would
never have the backbone to say in person
then what I do is immediately block you
I'm not if you I'm not going to have and
I'm not having a conversation with
Twitter's about a conversation I have
seven hundred twenty thousand followers
I'm not having a conversation it's not
arrogance I just can't realistically
logistically have a conversation with
all of you who have an opinion sorry
so my Twitter account is more about me
just sending out you know bible quotes
and other things to inspire you and make
you think sometimes something's funny
sometimes something makes you mad but
makes you think and that's what it's for
and then some people think that I'm
supposed to get an argument with them on
Twitter I'm not going to argue with you
sometimes people say something stupid to
me on Twitter and I respond once and
then when they respond back to argue I
just block them cuz I'm not gonna argue
with you I'm right why would I argue
with you it's ridiculous
so since I and I probably have more
blocked more people than any other
person with 700,000 followers I need to
have my social media guys pull it up I
don't have a tool that tells me how many
are blocked but it's probably 10,000
easy because anytime somebody says
something stupid
and you know and mean and hateful other
you start dropping cuss words in there
I'm not putting up with that I'll just
block you or if you're too holy if you
have a if you're what Michael what is it
Michael jr. says you're over saved if
you want those people it's over saved
like every fortune cookie you add to the
end of it and Jesus you know if you're
one of those people and Jesus and Jesus
you're over saved you won't use a Dirt
Devil to vacuum your house because
you're saved you're over saved if you're
that guy I'm not putting up with you
either because you're just icky
Christian like icky Christians driving
me nuts so you know everything's and
Jesus in Jesus and Jesus Jesus was a
socialist no Jesus was not a socialist
your block and so
that kind of stuff anyway so it's only
fair if I do that that a bunch of you
say mean and nasty things also we have a
high school curriculum that is taught in
tens of thousands of high schools 34% of
the hospitals in America teach our Dave
Ramsey's foundations in personal finance
which is a wonderful thing that it's in
the classes had I've been a high school
student in class and was I forced to
watch Dave Ramsey talk about getting out
of debt I would have had something
snarky to say we didn't have Twitter in
those days we got sent out of class to
get our butt busted if we said something
snarky but today you put it on Twitter
if you have something snarky to say so
these young people who don't understand
that millions of people see something
when you tweet it potentially they tweak
things too now I don't mess with them
because their kids
I have actually accidentally retweeted a
couple of because I didn't realize they
were teens and and then my tribe jumps
all over their butts but that's not
that's not what we do so I don't mess
with them but we do collect the mean
things that kids say while they're
sitting in class some say nice things
too but we don't collect those this is a
mean tweet segment so we'll start with
mean tweets from the students visualize
yourself sitting in a high school class
being forced to watch Dave Ramsey say
get on a budget don't have a credit card
get out of debt never have a car loan
and so on Jarret says mr. Franklin's
class for it went from not that bad to
my least favorite class thanks to Dave
Ramsey there you go
queen of All Saints says Dave Ramsey is
like a sexist overlord of finance there
you go Maggie says I don't know why my
math teacher is making us write an essay
over Dave Ramsey's seven baby steps I
think he's in love with him
however when Maggie said make us write
an essay she spelled it righ T it
doesn't fail spell check but it fails
Abby says yeah well Dave Ramsey can ke
MA
what's that mean
I know Kelly Kelly's telling me okay it
took me four and a half hours to do that
homework
well kid you're slow that homeworks not
that tough and that curriculum really
Bryn says when I envision how he'll
tortures people it's people watching the
Dave Ramsey education series Wow okay
then we'll get to the others the others
that are not students getting blocked by
Dave Ramsey is my greatest
accomplishment fairly low on the success
bar are we peace peace is the name
that's pretty that tells you right there
done it Bailey says Dave Ramsey's head
reminds me too much of a bowling ball
I'm stuck with a brother
I don't really disagree with you Jordan
says I'd rather walk through broken
glass barefoot than take Dave Ramsey's
Financial Peace University okay you can
actually walk across coals barefoot if
you take Tony Robbins class but we don't
do glass I don't know anybody does glass
voluntarily but Dave Ramsey aka a man
who likes to get in front of an audience
and make fun of the poverty-stricken
people in the US yeah that happens all
time Jack Mia says Dave Ramsey is
Colonel santur Sanders do not fight me
in this hot chicken baby my chicken love
it Justin says Dave Ramsey is the new
Hitler Wow I don't know if I want to
respond to that Maddie says Dave Ramsey
is the most unrealistic person I know
hashtag cash for college hashtag not
happening there you go
when Haley says me Dad Dave Ramsey says
credit cards are bad dad well Dave
Ramsey is a freaking idiot he kids
called that all the time James is this
all you could find there's more than
that I've seen more than that this
week those are the ones that were clean
enough to be show the ones that were
clean enough to use okay
well there's always that I guess hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you are not a victim you're not a victim
of big corporations you're not a victim
of Wall Street you're not a victim of
capitalism you're not a victim of wealth
inequality you're not a victim of racism
you're not a victim